(triumphant theme music)
- Where's Dana and Julia?
- For the love of God, get
your burnt holes out of here!
Biatches!
- Hand bump!
- You know who I think's cute?
- Your dad?
- Ew gross, grow up Julia!
(laughter)
- I'm trying to
tell you a secret.
I wanna do it with
Hot Hairy Croatian.
- The freshman exchange student?
Me too, but you can't do
it with someone before me.
- I promise you I won't.
Let's add him to the Do It Book.
(urinating)
- Me heard you, I like
to do it to you both too.
At three o'clock
behind learning zone.
See you little
queef-monkeys later.
- Oh my God, we're gonna
do it at the same time
with Hot Hairy Croatian.
- Best friends forever!
Doing things together!
- Doing things together!
- What does queef-monkey mean?
- One of my mom queefs
when she laughs.
That means her cha-cha burp.
- Hmm, Hot Hairy Croatian
must want us to queef-monkey.
- But does that mean we
gotta get air in there?
- It sure does!
- Hmm.
- See, I told you.
Ms. Klitnick always has
balloons for Shabbat.
- So we're skipping class
only to sneak back in?
- This is going to be the most
important sexual experience
of our lives and we
have to be ready.
No follow me bush.
- Hmm.
(loud fart)
- [Class] Ew! Gross!
- Devil woman! That just
got in my goddamn mouth.
- (Speaks foreign language)
- Sorry children, I've been so
backed up from all the kugel
I ate at Nahama Fingerman's
Triple Double Babas'.
- (Speaks foreign language)
- Bub, use English language.
Ow, that hurt me! That
hurt Ms. Klitnick.
Levi, you have five minutes.
Rest your body in the
principle's office.
- Gonna go get my dick sucked!
- Someone threw us some
perfectly good matzo balls!
Oh wee, I love matzo ball soup!
- Uh, uh, uh, this feels
weird but it's fun.
- This feels really
really weird.
Boy are we gonna be prepared.
(school bell rings)
- In my country, this
is how we make horny.
Osh, osh, osh, osh, osh, osh.
- Is this the sex?
- Yep, sure is.
Feels queer.
(both laugh)
(loud farting sound)
- My vagina's burping!
- Me too, it's tickly.
- You are disgusting me.
Osh, osh, osh, osh, osh.
- Uppercut, hi ya!
(both laugh)
I can't believe we're
not virgins anymore.
- I can't believe we're finally
real, live grown up women.
Hand bump!
- Hand bump!
♪ Girl I wanna do it!
♪ Don't you wanna do it!
♪ Can we do it!
(triumphant theme music)